all right welcome to a very special
edition of a master in the middle game i
am your host Mike hummer filling in for
the prestigious Yasser Sarah Juan
tomorrow night the Archbishop's the st.
Louis Archbishop managed by yours truly
will play in the western conference
finals of the u.s. chess league so
hopefully you guys can all come and and
watch that and cheer on the team we're
going to be watching two very
spectacular games from the season the
first game is between a feed a master
dog eckert with the white pieces against
national master a to you of the eddie
from dallas well actually playing dallas
tomorrow and our Spencer fine goal will
be manning board three so here we go so
white starts out with the move d4 Knight
f6 Bishop attacks the night does anybody
know what this is called what is it trap
house key very good so black plays the
move c5 so you could just take and give
the amana double pawns right away but he
decides to push it so Queen to be six
attacks the beep on so Doug is like I
don't care if you take it I'm going to
get a rapid lead in development so
Bishop comes back to d2 so we're
threatening a rook to be one followed by
night to be five here so Queen just
retreats instantly back to be 6 so now
white goes for e 4 and black plays v5
now just because you can
% doesn't mean you should as unsent
would be a very bad for white in this
position so instead he decides to just
attack the pawn with f4 it's a black
protects the pawn with d6 ok so now
white needs to get serkan some pieces
out and an attack in the center so
Knight f3 keep piling on The Ed pawn so
night protects the e pawn rook attacks
the Queen Queen retreats so now Doug
takes Knight takes takes pawn takes
alright so now [ __ ] up the b5 check so
you're in check you got to get out of it
so Bishop per text ok so white gets
castled and now black is threatening the
castle here ok so this is obviously
called master in the middle game so now
we need some ideas for white here that
we have any ideas
so let's look at mark sure well ok so
now white is castled obviously they're
out of opening theory by now so it's
basically transitioned into the middle
game here so do we have any ideas so so
the big idea is black isn't castled yet
right if he gets castled it's not going
to be very fun for wait because we're
down a pawn right so if Black gets
castled you know we're pretty much just
down upon for nothing and we have no
concrete nothing concrete for it we're
just down a point but if blacks King
remains in the center all game good news
yes
all right Erik Erikson though trying to
get something okay Bishop g5 okay
excellent so that is what is played in
the game Bishop to g5 so now we're
threatening stuff so if Blackwood
dubiously castle in this position yes
Eric d6 let's see
and then we're in a lot of trouble black
is in a lot of trouble okay like a lot
of trouble right we move our queen it
doesn't matter and then yeah look Knight
takes and yet the rook is protecting the
night piatek rexer with the bishop here
and then now we're threatening things
like Queen a g4 check and we're doing
very well here okay so so okay so we
cannot castle at least not King site is
actually best bet here is actually
castling Queen side but that's also very
very dangerous okay so so he replies
with the move rook to d8 okay
rook d8 so you want to just play d6
anyway okay so if we would play d6 now
he could take with the Queen I think and
I mean it still isn't this still isn't
very good for good for black but he is
not going to get checkmated where's when
the queens are on the board he might get
checkmated or it's a white plays takes
Bishop takes now the move d 6 so the
Queen's got to move Queen the c8 so now
you know castle een might be something
he might want to consider in this
position right I did not tell you what
the main theme of this lecture is about
all I 12 besides the u.s. chesley games
because if I told you that you would
know instantly what the with the move is
where did you say Claudio rook takes f6
yeah so it's about sacrificing the
exchange because cuz look if if he ever
gets castled here like if we just pass
or something goofy like that and he gets
castled I mean he's just going to be up
upon and life is going to be good so so
we have to keep the King in the center
obviously you can still theoretically
castle but nobody wants to castle into
this broken home here so so let's see
what we can do now what is the follow-up
now and it's a very
very interesting move well maybe not yet
how about how about just 95 right well
next to d5 it does look promising and
because you're threatening a lot of
different checks but Doug does pick the
best move and the cute move here with
Queen to g4 obviously he can't take it
because it's in a pin okay so so now
black decides to play Bishop the c6 so
now what is under attack of whites here
yes Queen and Bishop break so so we have
to know that but obviously Doug knows
and so there's only one move that looks
very natural here and it's Queen attacks
the rook and the pond so obviously he
doesn't want to play a move like this
cuz yeah is that well well it might as
well be dead right how is this still not
checkmate it's coming up all right thank
you yeah all right so anybody can see
that okay so so okay so he's got to play
work to fa now night to d5 well you
would think night to d5 would be good
here
let's check the engine real quick
night-night the d fives got to be pretty
good here it's not even winning how can
that be alright so in the game dog plays
the move rook to d1 so black plays Queen
to e6 so obviously now now night the d5
has got to be the move alright so night
to d5 obviously threatening a the big
fork here where we win the Queen are the
yep so so now black probably only has
one move he can play here what move is
it to save everything
wait wait what's the move cooking the d7
run get out so King to d7 let's see what
we can do here what about what about
this move where is that Queen going now
bill okay too good boo all right he got
out he got out yeah all right so if King
d7 night takes up six check so after
Bishop to c4 okay so now instead of
moving our night to c7 right away
ah
haha I'm running oh he's running yeah
yeah yeah the delayed castle alright so
after Queenie 695 so so King d7 does
look good but I'm sure the computer has
a refutation let's check it out let's
check you know they do like the night c7
move what are we missing o Queen to g4
check I knew there had to be something
all right and then the game is a kaput
alright alright so the move is Queen
tags d6 and he concedes a check
Knight takes up six check and so now
Knight takes f6 check is played so he
does not want to play King to e7
yeah queen of six is not mate but it
yeah discovered check their sale and you
drop the Queen yep so it's always like
all right I'm just going to take the
Queen so after Queen takes rook takes
check and then King up all right so now
King black plays king the d7 now we
might have a trick here for white hi
Eric yeah he loves tricks so let's see
what his knee Whitney green g7 excellent
because if he's like oh man I better
protect my rook get them far away Queen
the g4 check and then boom right
obviously uh obviously this trick
doesn't work because of work to da but
it's pretty nice though because now you
get that guy wherever he goes and then
you can get this guy annual life is good
a dog unfortunately doesn't doesn't play
this this end game to perfection and
let's black it a lot of counter play so
but notice how you know he kept the
pressure on the whole the whole way
through in the middle game and now he
got a slight advantage going into the
same game but a fortune cannot convert
it gets that pawn the works get doubled
which is very important cleanup gets a
check in King up and you know good
this is going to be really tough for it
for either player to really win in this
position here and we'll just show how it
concludes here gets the check in so now
Doug does not want to get check so he he
kind of hides in the corner here Queen
attacks the rook and the pawn rook up
Queen up here King the b7 and you know
blacks I mean all his pawns are pretty
much protected so it's going to be
really tough for him to ever win this
I'm sure he's going to play this check
here in check King up Queen gets the
four and once he plays this now with
rook to be seven what do you think dog
is going to try to do in this position
from from here on out what do you think
his idea is Eric yeah you nope nope take
professional check yeah just check them
forever and drunk no joy I mean but but
unfortunate he could he could never get
the closing blow in but but yet when
you're your opponent hasn't castled you
know even if you want to sacrifice the
exchange go for it you know just keep
the pedal to the metal and and who knows
maybe you can break through eventually
all right so here is the next game
bigness yes it's a Elliott Lou he had a
spectacular season in the in the US
chess leagues for the Las Vegas desert
rats he went 10 and 0 and in this game
he played big nish
pension athan from San Francisco Elliot
Lou had the white pieces here and I'm
sure he's going to sacrifice the
exchange in this in this game here ok so
white starts out Elliot head white pc
starts out d4 Knight f6 night up c4 c6
the slaw break some ice love so happy
alright so II six III all right it's all
pretty common stuff Bishop takes so so
when black takes this pawn here yeah
he's gaining the tempo but giving up
control of e four so it's something to
think about so he attacks the Bishop
Bishop Beck develops the bishops oh so
now Elliott gets in me for so pulling
attacks the night so the night moves c5
attacks the night night up and now white
gets castled pawn takes so so Elliot did
not want to take back obviously or else
you know night would take e five if you
can but they're not letting them but
that's what would happen so it plays
work to e1 protects the pawn and black
has no good way to protect the deep one
so Bishop e7 night takes and black gets
Castle okay so now we're in the middle
game everybody's castled Elliot's got a
night on the rim here but it really
can't move but he's got a lot a lot of
stuff going on up here okay so so notice
like if you if you go down the line
right like King side Queen side right
you notice that black only has a rook in
a bishop on the King side right and the
it really isn't defending the king at
all right so what do you think white
might want to do here attack right right
if everybody is on the other side right
okay so so we could threaten a checkmate
right off the bat we would consider
momentarily maybe this but we have no we
have no night check or and this Queen
check why is it not letting me go or you
get the point all right he finally gets
the Chi eight and but you have no follow
really okay so so will dismiss that
because we can easily calculate that
okay we could play Queen h5 and threaten
the checkmate right but then he would
play g6 and checkmate a stop so what's
the only other decent move we have here
yes Eric yeah you were looking at the
whole time right now the whole time it's
a quick Queen to g4 okay so now we're on
the same file as the king excellent so I
don't even know what he can do so what
so so X i dunno what you can do but what
so if what is white threatening here now
Bishop h6 okay so so we need to
calculate that oh my God he's going to
play Bishop 86 and checkmate me so if we
play King AJ now
nope here keeps looking at all the moves
all right so so anyway a blacks opponent
is uh is very good the Vinglish play in
black is 2386 so he sees I'll play rook
to e8 and then after Bishop 86 what is
he going to play to stop mate Bishop fa
stops mate so okay so he's calculating
so that's good so now Elliott decides
okay I'm not going to get the checkmate
over there so I'm going to start just
doing tactics here so he puts puts the
night in a pin okay and notice that you
know things like night to c5 can be
played now because well probably not
because night would just take and then
Bishop take here you wouldn't want to do
that but what ideas like that or it in
that in the head at least so he's like I
don't want to be in a pain i'm playing a
six right away so Bishop takes Queen
takes and now the move Knight to c5 can
be played because obviously if he takes
like yeah computer can't wait to play it
checkmate real or oh right yeah night
beats the upper so night to see Five
Forks the Queen and the abisha Pierre so
f five attacks the Queen so he wants to
make a threat greater equal than aliens
and now notice the queen is protecting
the checkmate as well as the bishop so
so le it's got to just take the Queen
pawn takes the Queen and now which piece
of Eliot's is under attack currently
the bishop on a sec so he's got to do
something about that so he retreats it
okay so King to f7 okay so he's like I'm
going to take your bishop so rook takes
so now Elliot I think is just going to
start attacking so rook to e4 he sees
the night has no no good places you know
because obviously you'll get a
discovered attack so if the night you
know retreat somewhere you know you just
take the pole so he's like I don't want
to do that alright so so he protects the
pond h5 he attacks the pawn and with f3
so pawn takes f3 knight takes f3 so now
he protects the part ok so see how with
Elliot's one book move he's got to
defend a lot of pawns here so night gets
back centralized the d4 so where do you
think that night is going to be headed
d6 right so he does nothing to prevent
him from going there so obviously he's
going to well first he wants to get out
of this Bishop Knight rook pin so so
okay well not a pin but a discovered
attack so he attacks the pond so his
opponent defends it and now he goes to
be five so now he attacks it it's a
little late so I'm going to d6
so broke up Bishop attacks the rook rook
moves okay so do you think so this this
has actually been blacks first what
aggressive move well besides bicha
basics I guess so obviously black wants
to play b3 and get his uh his rook act
so Elliot just wants no part of it and
plate Ray's work back and then you can
be thinking about rook elf three
checkmate sound good so now the king
wants to get out of there so rook f3 I
play it anyway it's no good to throw in
a check so he's like I'm not good i
don't want to get checked up there
because a skewer obviously alright so so
I only it's going to check in with the
other rook here King up ok ok so so go
ahead and say what you were going to say
so Bishop e3 right so what could you
tell me he's only got one legal move
right ok so so you could say if that
darn night wasn't on d5 right I would
have checkmate so Danny Brooke f6 ok
Danny might have already seen this game
actually with me agreed you can agree to
disagree so work f6 ok yeah yeah ok so
rook f6 obviously if the night takes
which the computer is even going to let
me oh the book computer already played I
don't know how he knew but yet work the
c7 was played in the game and so now
rook takes c7 ok so hopefully the
computer won't play this move
instantaneously so notice how we just
like we can just
throw away material because you know
we're that good so after Knight takes f6
white has a shocker but notice he just
saw like wow if I throw my rook away on
f6 right I'll have mate maybe maybe just
maybe we might have a shocking move
again where it looks like we drop
material but it might be all in good fun
all right Eric so so what do we have
here so so weird to be seven check
unfortunately was not the winner because
if we just move the rook somewhere right
doesn't it so if we play something like
Brooke here you know he's going to move
the night to safety okay yeah did you
ever you have a suggestion yes yes you
oh well you know the answer you don't
remember okay so rook rook the c8 is the
shocking move you know but you know if
you're in the mode where you know you
just sacked a rook you know check out if
the other one is good so route to c8
it's kind of similar to be seven us up
now the the bishop is going to be in the
way of the queening square so pawn takes
bishop back and now obviously we just
push the pawn as fast as we can Bishop
up
and for no reason they decided i'm going
to play there but you might as well get
the get the queen rook takes Bishop
takes and now it's going to be a pretty
simple endgame but he plays a place good
technique gets a passer gives them a
check tax the night or tomorrow night
attacks the bishop and you know just
bring the King up get them centralized
attack obviously we just take here and
who would play h4 in this position yeah
good yeah I attacks you'd just put play
it yeah no reason to give them any hope
and you know now I can't advance
anything and I just play a 4 and he's
off to the races and uh and that's that
so that was Elliot loser excellent gave
me finish up as the MBP 10 and 0 but we
ended up eliminating the Las Vegas
desert rats last week and we'll be
playing dallas tomorrow Dallas will have
drawn but it'll be a lot of fun i'll be
i'll be here announcing it with somebody
somebody better than me so we'll get our
expert analysis and a it'll be a lot of
fun tomorrow at seven so hopefully
everybody can check that out and thank
you for participating mastering the
middle game